in the art gallery of a North German
city hangs a lurid oil painting which
represents two Italians waylaying and
attacking a third I will tell you the
history of the painting in the 90s of
the last century a young German painter
was living on the outskirts of Rome in
an isolated little house surrounded by a
vineyard one fine bright moonlit night
after sitting over the why until a late
hour
with two or three friends down in the
city he came home about midnight he had
to walk some distance beyond the end of
the streetcar line through a narrow road
that ran between high walls he never
came through that lane late at night
without a feeling of apprehension he was
a poor man he never wore jewelry his
modest brown cape and dilapidated broad
brimmed hat were very much like the
clothing of many of his modest neighbors
visibly not the appurtenances of a man
of means and he had had no love affairs
in Rome so it did not seem as if any
sort of ambush was likely he thought a
good deal about his fiancee back in
Germany and he almost always carried a
letter from her and his left inside best
pocket just over his heart as he walked
home he was in the habit of whistling to
keep his courage up of talking aloud to
himself bursting out every now and then
with that certainly a fact or yes I
think that's what I'll do
and he was likely to call out at
intervals to his little dog a Spitz who
never strayed far from his master's
heels he always carried a revolver on
his person although in all the years
since he had acquired it he had never
once had occasion to fire it off but
when he came near his garden gate he
never failed to find himself shivering
with apprehension till his slightly
trembling fingers had the gate unlocked
he can almost visualize a big fellow
gliding around the corner and stepping
out threatening Leigh in front of him he
always had his key in his hand before he
reached the gate and he always pushed
the key into the lock with nervous haste
on dark nights he would hold his lighted
cigar toward the lock with the other
hand then he would lock the gate behind
him in a great hurry unlock his house
door just as nervously light the candle
which stood waiting for him to the left
of the door on the uneven tile floor try
the door which led into the ground-floor
rooms all of the
unoccupied except the kitchen and
utilized as lumber rooms to store his
artists supplies and climb the creaking
stairs to the upper floor where were
located his spacious studio in his
little bedroom the bedroom was scarcely
more than an alcove and it always stood
wide open into the studio so that as he
lay in bed he could see the great wide
window and the starry heavens outside
his trip home on this particular evening
had not been without disquieting
incidents nothing very definite had
happened and he might have attached no
importance to anything that had occurred
if he had not been made a little
apprehensive by the eerie turn the
conversation in the artist group had
taken his spits had stopped and barked
furiously into a linden tree alley a few
hundred yards from his garden gate it
was true that the dog had a nervous
streak in him and often grew excited
over nothing at all a little earlier as
the artist was getting off the streetcar
a very suspicious-looking and acting man
in ragged work clothes had asked him how
to reach the valley San Giorgio a lonely
little Valley with a chapel in the
center of it a sort of ravine which lay
behind and below the eminence on which
his house was built and which no human
being and his senses would have thought
of visiting at that hour of the night
then as he came through the narrow
street between the high walls he could
have sworn he heard steps on the hard
ground behind him the impression was so
strong that he turned and looked back
more than once but no one was visible
and it was only while he himself was
walking that he seemed to hear the steps
they must have been only the echo of his
own steps and the uncanny stillness of
the night finally at a turn of the
crooked little Street he had come
suddenly within a few feet of a man who
was going in the same direction but more
slowly the man turned and looked at him
then walked slowly away on a path that
branched off from the little Street the
painter had had only an indefinite
impression of the man's bearded face but
his artist I had taken in the squat
heavy frame which stood out plainly in
the moonlight the peculiar swing of the
man's walk and even the wavering shadow
which showed rather distinctly on the
wall beyond him before he turned into
the footpath when he had himself come
abreast of the path and peered fearfully
down it the
and had disappeared there were no
buildings along the path and it was
distinctly visible for some distance it
seemed as if the earth had swallowed the
man or he might have dodged behind a
clump of bushes but why would he have
done that
it was strange for a few minutes the
young painter had been almost uneasy
then all at once the artist in him had
gained the upper hand he realized that
the shape and manner of the bearded
pedestrian had been very much what he
had had in mind for a figure in a
violent night scene which he was
planning to paint and he regretted that
he had not seen the man's face more
distinctly he began to lay plans for
sketching what he remembered of the face
and figure before he went to bed and in
his cheerful planning he completely
forgot his apprehension till his dog had
begun to bark frantically at the
entrance at the Linden Ali arrived at
home the painter had hauled his
preliminary sketch out of a corner set
it up on an easel and rapidly drawn in
with charcoal the outlines of the man
with a beard he had originally planned
to make this person the aggressor in an
encounter he had thought of him is
rushing out from his concealment behind
a wall and running with drawn sword at a
favorite rival who had just said goodbye
to a lady at the gate of an imposing
Palazzo but some mysterious influence
seemed to guide him into a change of
plan he of the beard must be the victim
not the attacker and he must be set upon
by two men the painter took out a fresh
sheet and sketched in the new idea it
was curious how definitely the
impression had come to him he knew
exactly where to place each individual
how to direct each motion but the face
of the bearded defender the man whose
life was forfeit to these vicious
assassins would not come clear to him
finally he grew tired of searching
undressed and went to bed tomorrow he
said to himself when I am fresher I
shall be able to think the thing out
better
he went to sleep at once and slept
soundly but in the course of the night
he had no idea how long he had been
asleep he started up in bed with the
definite impression that he had heard
something a call a cry or voices talking
together
he listened complete silence if he had
heard anything it must have been in his
dream it did seemed to him as if he had
had a dream and that he had dreamed
about something disturbing something
alarming but he could not remember what
the dream had been about he was in the
act of lying down again when he glanced
into his studio which lay bathed in the
moonlight from the great window he saw
his dog standing erect in the center of
the room his head thrust forward and
turned toward the window watching and
listening intently without barking he
had never seen the animal act like that
before the painter called softly the dog
gave no sign of hearing him he did not
change in the slightest his attitude of
absorbed interest then the painter
raised his eyes to the window at first
it seemed to him as if he must be
dreaming still he threw the bedclothes
aside stared at the window brushed his
hands across his eyes and gazed again
there was no doubt about it
the painters eyes were looking into the
eyes of the bearded man whose conduct
had puzzled him the night before it
looked as if the man had climbed up and
stood on something that lifted him
breast high before the second-story
window the rough bones carelessly kept
face with a tangled hair and beard was
unmistakably the face he had caught a
glimpse of on his way home a few hours
before it was frightfully distorted the
eyes were wide open and staring the lips
were open and drawn back from the teeth
it seemed almost as if the man were
uttering a terrified cry for help but
not a sound was audible on the left
temple there was an ugly wound with the
hair matted over it but with the blood
still trickling down over the face there
was no sign of the hands the arms fell
straight down from the shoulders it
almost seemed to the painter as he
studied the figure in its attitude a
little more calmly as if someone had
pushed a dead man up into the window
from below
then all at once the horrible apparition
disappeared noiselessly and the painter
saw the trees in the quiet sky behind
and above them at that moment the dogs
muscles relaxed from his position of
tense watchfulness he ran to his master
cowered against him as if seeking
protection turned his head back toward
the window then he sat down expectantly
before the painter exactly as he was in
the habit of doing when he saw the
artist take down his hat and his caped
cloak to go out for a moment the
distracted artist could do nothing but
stare at the rectangle of moonlight
where the ghastly figure had been then
he realized the changed attitude of the
dog and spoke to the animal when the
little creature saw that he had his
master's attention he stood up wagged
his tail and looked around expectantly
toward the stairway the artist took his
revolver and went to the window the
moonlit landscape was calm and silent
not a sight or a sound if a gang of
assassins had held a murdered man up to
his window a minute or two before they
could scarcely have made so completed
getaway in so short a time
the shutters on the window below were
closed and locked there was nothing to
climb up by and except for the feeling
that he had heard something in his dream
the painter was sure that not a sound
had reached him from outside the
building the dog ran back and forth
between the artist and the stairway
animals have remarkable leadings
and the painter thought seriously of
making the rounds of the garden but it
seemed to him as he thought it over that
such a procedure would be useless at
best and that it worst it would be
courting trouble if bandits were about
what could one timid citizen armed with
an old revolver that had never been
fired in its life do against them all
that could be expected of him certainly
was to watch from inside his house till
morning he closed his window and ordered
the dog back to his cushion just before
he drew the window down he had had the
impression that he heard steps run
rapidly along the stone pavement that
lay just below it he raised it again and
looked down
no one was in sight and not a sound was
to be heard he stood by the window
struggling to get a grip on himself he
wondered if he could be ill he knew that
various delusions came from physical
causes within the one who experiences
them he had tried so desperately hard to
visualize the head which he needed for
his picture that his effort combined
with the effect of the heavy flare-nut
wine he had drunk might easily have
produced a psychic effect which caused
him to see visions and hear sounds that
had transpired only in his imagination
he had almost convinced himself that he
had found the key to the enigma when his
glance fell on his dog obediently
crouching on his cushion but still
wide-eyed and excited it seemed to him
exactly as if someone spoke out from
right behind him but what about the dog
does your psychopathic theory explain
the way the dog is acting suddenly the
painters mood of anxiety and puzzlement
gave way to one of impatience he was
tired and nervous he was disgusted with
the whole annoying affair he dropped on
his bed again and in a mood of something
like defiance he flung off the
perplexity and dropped into a heavy
sleep nothing happened till morning when
the bright sun shone into the window
instead of the ghostly moon he was ready
to laugh the whole matter off as a half
tipsy dream and to class the dog strange
conduct with various other evidences of
unaccountable nervousness which that
animal had shown at various times he sat
down at his easel and went seriously to
work at his new sketch he discovered
that he knew the bearded face now
feature by feature and the task went
smoothly it was marvellous how vividly
the face and form of the heavy fellow
came out under the artists eager fingers
this would be his best picture he was
sure of that as he was working he heard
somebody knock at the door downstairs he
made a few rapid strokes still hastily
kicked off his slippers and pulled on
his shoes and went down it was doubtless
the peasant woman he thought who brought
him his milk every morning but he
brought it at the most unaccountably
irregular hours if she wasn't willing to
follow a fairly even schedule there was
no reason why he should discommode
himself to keep her from waiting a
minute or two
when he opened the door there was no
woman there and no milk can he strolled
down the walk toward the fountain at
which the milk woman often stopped to
water her donkey as he came near the
fountain he heard voices when he passed
the clump of bushes that had hidden the
place for miss sight he discovered an
excited group arguing and gesticulating
about some object which lay on the
ground there were two policemen in the
group has something happened he inquired
as he joined the circle they killed a
man last night said one of the
bystanders one of the policemen asked
the painter if he had seen or heard
anything that might throw any light on
the mystery
he was about to tell his ghost story
when it occurred to him how improbable
it was and he contented himself with
replying that as he had walked home late
at night a man in front of him had
turned it is a little side path and that
before he had left the streetcar a man
had asked the way to the valley San
Giorgio would you know the man in front
of you if you saw him again the painter
was not sure but he thought he
remembered certain things about him for
example he remembered very distinctly
that the man had a beard the policeman
looked up quickly is this the man he
asked and drew off the sack which had
covered the head of the prostrate form
the painter started back in terror and
for a moment his voice failed him
completely there was the head he had
seen in the window the eyes still
staring wide the matted hair clinging
about the wound over the left temple the
wild scraggly beard the look of anguish
an appeal was still in the eyes that
gazed up into the eyes of the painter as
if the deed were not yet committed and
the man was begging him to come to his
aid and as the living man gazed with
fascinated horror into the eyes of the
dead man the expression of the eyes
seemed to change to one of her approach
the little dog had been ready and
anxious to dash out and help defend the
victim of a band of assassins but his
master had been too stupid too selfish
too cowardly to come to the assistance
of a fellow being in distress the
painter recovered his self-control
and said dully to the policeman yes I
think that was the man
did you know him as one of the neighbors
with whom the German painter had a
bowing acquaintance and when the painter
shook his head
the voluble Italian prattled on it is
much better that the bandits made away
with this man than if they had killed a
gentleman like you he was and he touched
his finger compassionately to his
forehead from the general discussion
that followed the artists learned that
the dead man who for a good part of his
life had been a Shepherd in the Alban
Hills was a strange dreamer of a fellow
who claimed to have the gift of second
sight to be able to foretell the future
and to have the power to cure disease by
prayer members of the group told various
stories of strange proofs of his psychic
powers notably of one instance in which
he had described in great detail a fire
which was raging at that same moment in
a town a hundred miles away and of which
he had no possible means of knowledge it
is strange said one of the neighbors
thoughtfully that he didn't foresee what
would happen to him when he came out
here last night perhaps he did foresee
it said one of the policemen who had
been looking through a handful of papers
which had come from one of the dead
man's pockets among these papers many of
them old and worn from long friction in
the pocket was a clean sheet on which
was printed out very carefully I am
going a hard way perhaps I shall not
come back but I am saving another man's
life
the murderers were caught a few days
later they were two vagabonds of known
evil habits both of whom had already
served prison sentences when they were
examined they confessed that they had
intended to kill the painter and plunder
his isolated house at their leisure but
that in their excitement they had
mistaken one man for another who was
dressed very similarly they had intended
they said to break into the studio that
same night but had been so frightened
when the dying Shepherd had called their
attention to their blunder and had
warned them solemnly never to carry out
their murderous plan against the painter
that they had taken to their heels in a
panic and so it comes that the picture
of the half-crazy Italian Shepherd who
saved the life of a young German painter
is hanging today in a German art gallery
[Music]
[Music]
the sound of a shot suddenly broke the
stillness of the may morning and echoed
back from across the valley a puff of
blue smoke arose from a clump of green
briars and drifted away downwind out in
the road
Abner Simmons dropped the bag of grain
he was carrying and with a look of dumb
surprise sank in a quivering heap to the
ground half his side had been shot away
the green briars parted with a sudden
life and Jed Tolliver emerged
straightening his long form as he
shambled toward the road as he walked he
broke his double-barreled shotgun
flicked out the empty cartridge and blew
through the barrel sending a thin stream
of acrid smoke out of the chamber he
stooped over his fallen enemy said I'd
get you he reminded the other brutally
he inserted a fresh cartridge and closed
the gun with a snap the man in the road
rolled over with a convulsive movement
and stared up at him that kid brother of
yours is next and last Jed continued
then I'll be through with the lot of you
Abner grinned it is an awful thing to
see a dying man grin Jed shuddered in
spite of himself
you can't Jed not Ezekiel it was not a
pleading rather it was calm assured as
though the other were stating a known
fact
Jed shuddered again before he felt quick
anger rising I got you didn't I he said
ejecting a thick stream of tobacco juice
what makes you think I won't get Ezekiel
the same way you won't Jed you can't
because I won't let you he was fast
weakening from the frightful flow of
blood overcome from the effort of
speaking Abner closed his eyes and lay
still a second later a sudden convulsive
movement shook his body and his eyes
opened again this time they were fixed
and staring with a grunt of satisfaction
Jed shouldered his gun and started back
up the mountain moving with the long
effortless stride of the Tennessee
Mountaineer
he did not fear punishment for his crime
here in the Tennessee mountains the long
arm of the law seldom reached the only
thing to fear in a case of this kind was
the dead man's relatives and now there
was only one Ezekiel a slim lad of 20
who could not even shoot expertly yes
Jed reflected as his long strides
carried him through the sparse growth of
cedar and blackjack this part of
Tennessee would soon again be a decent
god-fearing community foreigners the
Simmons has it been from somewhere back
east Carolina or Virginia maybe they
hadn't been like the mountain folk and
what was that crazy talk Abner had made
he'd stopped Jed from getting Ezekiel
how could he if he was dead Jed chuckled
to himself here in Tennessee folk didn't
believe more than a week passed before
Jed again took his well-oiled shotgun
from its place on the wall and started
over the mountain he was in no great
hurry about Ezekiel instead he rather
enjoyed waiting Ezekiel was the last of
the three Simmons brothers and knowing
that the foreigner was over there and
that he was going to kill him gave life
a curious sort of zest likely the kid
didn't even know who shot his brother
Jed laughed silently at the thought
adding to himself that the boy probably
wouldn't do anything about it if he did
no he wasn't like the mountain people
but this morning all of Jed's impatience
had returned the Sun shone hotly on the
Tennessee Hills and raised an almost
visible veil of vapor from the tiny
branches which sowed through the hollow
well he'd waited long enough
with a grimace of distaste at the 3-mile
traipse across two mountains Jed swung
his gun over his shoulder and started
down the slope when an hour and a half
later he arrived at the small clearing
which was the Simmons place he was not
as tired as he had expected to be the
nervous exhilaration of the manhunt
buoyed him up made him tensely aware of
things around him he paused only a
moment at the fringe of scrub oak that
bordered the clearing then bending
almost double he sprinted a hundred feet
to the great barber safe inside the
leafy bower
Jed leaned his gun against a supporting
post and looked about
here the vines had been trained over a
rude wooden lattice so that a thick wall
and roof of leaves now effectively hid
him from anyone outside Jed parted the
leaves carefully and peered out a
hundred feet behind him was the low wall
of forest he had just left 200 feet in
front of him was the house a rude to
room Shack 200 feet beyond that the wall
of the forest began again Jed looked at
the house more closely there was no sign
of movement but the thin line of smoke
which curled from the chimney told him
that Ezekiel was inside probably
preparing his midday meal with a sigh of
contentment he sat down and leaned back
closer to his gun
idly listening to the chatter of birds
in the forest and the rustling of the
leaves in the arbor how long Jed sat
there he did not know he was suddenly
aroused from a semi stupor by the sound
of a banging door startled into instant
activity he swung around to peer through
the leaves
Ezekiel was leaving the house swinging
in his hand an empty water bucket going
to the spring Jed reckoned if so his
path would take him within 50 feet of
the Arbor Jed gloated with hands
suddenly unsteady the man in the arbor
laid his gun on the ground
the muzzle barely extending through the
leaves why take a chance
he would wait at fifty feet he couldn't
miss on mindful of his danger Ezekiel
came slowly down the path bearing
diagonally nearer to the arbor Jed
suddenly wondered why he no longer heard
the aimless chatter of birds in the
forest why the light wind no longer
stirred the broad leaves above him it
was uncanny
this noonday quiet impatiently he shook
off the feeling so I can't do it Abner
he whispered to the empty air but
somehow the words clutched in his throat
and he wished he hadn't said it no
matter a few seconds now Jed cursed the
trembling of his hands as he aimed what
was the matter with him he could see
Ezekiel's slender form now above the
barrel of his gun he nerved himself to
pull the trigger the top of his head
suddenly gone cold
Jed dropped the gun and looked quickly
around him
no the day was bright as ever yet he
could have sworn half-heartedly now he
picked up the gun to sight at the forum
which had already passed the nearest
point he had not been wrong a black
nebulous cloud hovered over the barrel
of his gun and created the illusion of
darkest night shrieking a curse Jed
Tolliver left upright and pointed not
aimed the gun at where Ezekiel should be
he snapped both triggers simultaneously
but as he fired something clutched at
his arm
and the hot LED sizzled harmlessly
through the air shaking as with a chill
blind rage within him struggling with
black fear the Mountaineers stood
irresolute Lea within his leafy ambush
he was quickly aroused to activity by a
loud report and the crash of lead
against the wooden lattice a sharp pain
burned his left arm where one of the
pellets had found its mark Ezekiel had
fled to the house and opened fire
without winning to reload his gun
Jed crashed through the side of the
Bower and fled to the safety of the
trees as he entered buckshot spattered
harmlessly around him safe within the
sheltering growth Jed halted to reload
his gun
damn you Abner he shouted to the stunted
Oaks
I'll get him yet as he turned to go he
thought he heard a low mocking laugh but
reason later that it was only a squirrel
chattering a protest at the sound of his
voice
Jen reached home in a blue funk the long
[ __ ] across the mountains in the early
summer heat had melted away most of his
fears but his nerves were still badly
shaken now that he could look at the
incident in a sober light he refused to
credit his senses as the distance
between himself and the scene increased
he had come more and more to believe the
occurrence of hallucination brought on
by the long walk through the heat after
all he recalled he had almost fallen
asleep in the Arbor while waiting for
Ezekiel to appear perhaps he had dreamed
part of it however logical Jed believed
his explanation he did not again go near
the Simmons place weeks past always he
promised himself that he would soon
finish the task so ingloriously begun
but day by day he waited until nearly
three months had gone at first he had
feared Ezekiel had recognized him in
those few seconds it had taken to sprint
from the gray barber to the cover of the
woods later as he heard nothing of it he
decided he was safe from that side the
end came in an unexpected manner one
afternoon early in August Jed had walked
to the village he stayed longer than he
had intended and shadows were already
growing along when he started home not
wishing to be out later than necessary
he took a shortcut through the woods
which would take him within a half mile
of the Simmons place the Sun was setting
as he entered the Simmons Hollow a half
mile below the house he felt vaguely
uneasy though he told himself he was not
frightened he found himself wishing for
the protection of his gun nervously his
hand strayed to the hunting knife stuck
in his belt and tested the Keen edge
walking diagonally across the hollow
which was largely devoid of trees he
turned aside to go around a cluster of
young Cedars which was directly in his
path
suddenly he drew back sharply again his
hand tested the Keen edge of that knife
but not this time from nervousness 200
feet beyond the Cedars on the smooth
unbroken grass floor of the hollow was a
man milking
his back was turned to the Cedars but
Jed thought he recognized that slim
youthful form he believed it was Ezekiel
stepping lightly one hand on his belts
where he could immediately grasp the
knife Jed moved into the open halfway
across the level space his hand moved
yet closer to the knife while the ghost
of a grin curved his lips without a
doubt it was Ezekiel Simmons the man
milking did not look up the milk jetted
into the half filled bucket with a low
murmur just loud enough to mask Jed's
guarded footsteps step by step Jed
advanced if only Ezekiel did not see him
if only the cow did not sense his
presence and turn unexpectedly step by
step further Jed was tense with
excitement
there was no midday Sun this time to
blind his eyes and fill his soul with a
nameless fear nor would he be unnerved
by the Twilight stillness it was always
still at sunset here in these mountains
ten feet now the milk still switched
into the pale uninterruptedly the steady
grinding of the cows molars never ceased
suddenly Jed tugged at his belts and
left for word got you he shouted aloud
but the exultant cry died suddenly into
a moan of horror the arm bearing the
knife poised high for the blow
Jed felt something like an electric
shock coerced through its length instead
of swinging forward to strike the man in
front of him the knife turned in his
hand his wrist and elbow bent at a crazy
angle and the razor-edge steel ripped
through the cords of his neck staggered
more by his realization of the awful
consequences than by present pain Jed
sank to the grass while gouts of blood
spurted from a torn jugular his first
mad terror passed he became aware that
Ezekiel was standing over him scorn
darkening his features
so it was you Tolliver Abner warned me
about you
I'd have got you too only Abner Abner
was a good brother he told me weeks
before he died that if anything happened
he'd guard me shed felt himself weakened
his head was strangely without weight
and objects around swam lazily in the
pale Twilight he lay back on the grass
should have got you Ezekiel shouldn't
have missed he murmured sleepily as the
shadows gathered he raised his head
slightly to listen was that a light
mocking laugh he heard in the grass
beside him he listened again before the
darkness came down no he could not be
sure
the watchman's flashlight printed a
white circle on the frosted glass black
lettered door Gregg chemical company
manufacturers AUSA Gregg president
private the watchman's hand closed on
the knob rattled the door in its frame
queer but tonight the sound had seemed
to come from in there
but that couldn't be he knew that mr.
Gregg and miss Carruthers carried the
only keys to the office so any intruder
would have been forced to smash the lock
maybe the sound came from the storage
room the watchman clumped along the
rubber matted corridor flung his weight
against that door it opened hard being a
ponderous metal fitted into a cork
casing the room was an airtight
fireproof vault really his shoes gritted
on the concrete floor as he prowled
among the big porcelain vats the
flashlight board through bluish haze to
the concrete walls acid fumes escaping
under the VAT lids made the haze and
seared the man's throat he hurried out
coughing and wiping his eyes it was damn
funny every night lately he heard the
same peculiar noise somewhere in this
wing of the building like a body
groaning and turning and restless sleep
it was it scared him he didn't mention
the mystery to anyone though he was an
old man and he didn't want mr. Gregg to
think he was getting too old for the job
I also think I was crazy if I told him
about it he mumbled
inside the office AUSA Gregg heard the
muttered words plainly he sat very still
in the big leather cushioned chair
hardly breathing until the scrape of the
watchman's feet had thinned away down
the hall there was no light in the room
to betray him
only the cherry colored tip of his cigar
which couldn't be visible through the
frosted glass door anyway it would be an
hour before the watchman's round brought
him past the office again AUSA Gregg had
that hour if he could screw up his nerve
to use it he took the frayed end of the
cigar from his mouth his hand which had
wasted to mere skin and bone these past
few months groped through the darkness
slid over the polished coolness of the
dictaphone hood and snapped the switch
machinery faintly word his fingers found
the tube and lifted it miss Carruthers
he snapped then he hesitated surely he
could trust Mary Carruthers he never
wondered about her before she'd been his
secretary for a dozen years lately since
he couldn't look after affairs himself
as he used to
she had practically run the business she
was 40 sensible unbeautiful and
tight-lipped hell he had to trust her
his voice plunged into the darkness what
I have to say now is intended for mrs.
Gregg's ears only she will take the
first boat home of course meet that boat
and bring her to the office since my
wife knows nothing about a dictaphone it
will be necessary for you to set this
record running as soon as you have done
so leave her alone in the room make sure
she's not interrupted for a half hour
that's all he waited a decent interval
the invisible needle peeled its thread
into the revolving wax cylinder Janette
muttered ASSA Greg and hesitated again
this wasn't going to be easy to say he
decided to begin matter-of-factly
as you probably know my will and the
insurance policies are in the vault at
the first national I believe you'll find
all of my papers in excellent order if
any questions arise consultant miss
Carruthers what I have to say to you now
is purely personal I feel my dear that I
owe you an explanation
that is God it came harder than he had
expected Jeanette he started in a fresh
you remember three years ago when I was
in the hospital you were in Palm Beach
at the time and I wired that there'd
been an accident here at the plant that
wasn't strictly so the fact is I'd
gotten mixed up with a girl he paused
shivering in the darkness a picture of
dots went before him the oval face
framed by gleaming swirls of lemon
tinted hair had pouting scarlet lips and
eyes whose allure was intensified by
violent makeup the full-length picture
of her included a streamlined full
blossomed and yet delectably lithe body
a costly enticing Broadway chorus orchid
as a matter of fact that was where he'd
found her I won't make any excuses for
myself
dasu greg said harshly i might point out
that you were always in Florida or
Bermuda or France and then I was a
lonely man but it wasn't just loneliness
and I didn't seek companionship I
thought I was making a last bout of
romance I was successful 60 and silly
and I did all the damn fool things I
even wrote letters to her the dictaphone
couldn't record the grimace that jerked
his lips she saved them of course and
by-and-by she put a price on them ten
thousand dollars dot claimed that one of
those filthy tabloids had offered her
that much for them and what was a poor
working girl to do
she lied I knew that I told her to bring
the letters to the office after business
hours and I'd take care of her I took
care of her all right I shot her
Jeanette he mopped his face with a
handkerchief that was already damp not
on account of the money you understand
it was the things she said after she had
tucked the bills into her purse vile
things about the way she had earned it
ten times over by enduring my beastly
kisses I'd really loved that girl and I
thought she'd cared for me a little it
was her hate that maddened me and I got
the gun out of my desk drawer
ASSA greg reached through the darkness
for the switch he fumbled for the bottle
which stood on the desk his hand
trembled spilling some of the liquor
onto his lap he drank from the bottle
this part of the story he'd skip it was
too horrible even to think about it he
didn't want to remember how the blood
pooled inside dots for a coat and how
he'd managed to carry the body out of
the office without leaking any of her
blood onto the floor he tried to forget
the musky sweetness at the perfume on
the dead girl mingled with that other
evil blood smell especially he didn't
want to remember the frightful time he'd
had stripping the gold rings from her
fingers and the one gold tooth in her
head the horror of it coiled in the
blackness about him his own teeth
rattled against the bottle when he
gulped the second drink he snapped the
switch savagely but when he spoke his
voice cringed into the tube I carried
her into the storage room I got the lid
off one of the acid tanks the VAT
contained an acid powerful enough to
destroy anything except gold in fact the
VAT itself had to be lined with gold
leaf I knew that in 24 hours there
wouldn't be a recognisable body left and
in a week there wouldn't be anything at
all no matter what the police suspected
they couldn't prove a murder charge
without a corpus delicti I had committed
the perfect crime except for one thing I
didn't realize that there'd be a splash
when she went into the VAT Greg laughed
not pleasantly his wife might think it
had been a sob when she heard this
record now you understand why I went to
the hospital he jerked possibly you'd
call that poetic justice Oh God his
voice broke again he thumbed off the
switch and mopped his face with the damp
linen the rest
how could he explain the rest of it he
spent a long minute arranging his
thoughts
you haven't any idea he resumed no one
has any idea of how I'd been punished
for the thing I did I don't mean the
sheer physical agony but the fear that
I'd talk coming out of the ether at the
hospital the fear that she'd be traced
to my office I'd simply hidden her rings
away expecting to drop them into the
river or that she might have confided in
her lover yes she had won her suppose a
whopping big order came through and that
tank was empty the very next day and I
couldn't ask any questions I didn't even
know what was in the papers however that
part of it gradually cleared up I
quizzed miss Carruthers and learned that
an unidentified female body had been
fished out of the East River
a few days after doc disappeared that's
how the police solved the case I got rid
of her rings I ordered that VAT left
alone the other thing began about six
months ago a spasm contorted his face
his fingers ached their grip into the
dictaphone tube Jeanette you remember
when I began to object to the radio how
I shout out you to turn it off in the
middle of a program you thought I was
ill and worried about business you were
wrong the thing that got me was hearing
her voice he grips the cold cigar chewed
it it's very strange that you didn't
notice it no matter what station we
dialed to always that same voice came
stealing into the room but perhaps you
did notice you said once or twice that
all those blues singers sounded alike
and she was a blues singer it was she
all right somewhere out in the ether
reminding me
the next thing was well at first when I
noticed it in the office I thought miss
Carruthers had suddenly taken up with
young ideas you see I kept smelling
perfume and he smelled it now it was
like a miasma in the dark it isn't
anything that Carruthers wears he graded
it comes from yes the storage room I
realized that about a month ago just
after you sailed one night I stayed late
at the office and I went in there it
seemed to be strongest around the VAT
her VAT and I lifted the lid the sweet
sticky musk smell hit me like a blow in
the face and that isn't all terror
stalked in this room AUSA Gregg crouched
in his chair felt the weight of fear on
him like a submarine pressure his cigar
pitched to his knees dropped to the
floor you won't believe this Jeannette
he hammered the words like nails into
the darkness in front of him you'll say
that it's impossible I know that it is
impossible it's a physiological
absurdity it contradicts the laws of
natural science but I saw something on
the bottom of that VAT he groped for the
bottle his wife would hear a long gurgle
and then a coughing gasp the VAT was
nearly full of this transparent oily add
he went on what I saw was a lot of
sediment on the golden floor and there
shouldn't have been any sediment the
stuff utterly dissolves animal tissue
bone even the common ores keeps them in
suspension it didn't look like sediment
either it looked like a heap of mould
grave mould
I replaced the lid I spent a week
convincing myself that it was all
impossible that I couldn't have seen
anything of the sort
then I went to the VAT again silence
hung in the darkness while he sucked
wind into his lungs and the words burst
separate yammering shrieks I looked
night after night for hours at a time
I've watched the change did you ever see
a body decompose of course not
neither have I but you must know in a
general way with the processes well this
has been the exact opposite
first I stared at the heap of grave mold
as it shaped itself into bones a
skeleton
I watched the coming of hair a yellow
tangle of its sprouting from the bare
round skull until God the flesh began
making itself before my eyes I couldn't
bear any more I stayed away didn't come
to the office for five days the tube
slipped from his sweating slick fingers
panting ah so Greg fumbled in the dark
until he found it exhaustion not
self-control flattened his voice to a
deadly monotone I tried to think of a
way out if I could fish the corpse out
of the tank but I couldn't smuggle it
out of the plant alone you know that and
so do i besides what would be the use if
acid can't kill her nothing can that's
why I can't have the lid cemented on it
wouldn't do any good either until three
days ago she hadn't the least colour
looked as white as a ghost in the VAT a
naked ghost because there's been no
resurrection for her clothing I've
watched her limbs grow rosy her lips are
scarlet her eyes are bright they opened
yesterday and her breasts were rising
and falling almost imperceptibly but
that was last night
and tonight I swear it her lips moved
she muttered my name
she turned she'd been lying on her side
over onto her back the record would be
badly blurred his hands shook violently
bobbled the tube against his lips
Greg braced his elbow against the desk
she isn't dead he choked she's only
asleep not very soundly asleep she's
waking up the invisible needle quivered
as it traced several noises there was
his tortured breathing and the clawing
of his fingernails rattling over the
desk the drawer clicked as it opened the
loud click was the cocking of the
revolver soon she's going to get out of
that VAT Greg bleeded Jeanette forgive
me God forgive me but I will not I
cannot I dare not stay here to see her
then
the sound of the shock brought the
watchman's stumbling along the corridor
he crashed against the office door it
banged open in a shower of falling
frosted glass the watchman's flashlight
severed the darkness and printed its
white circle on the face of AUSA Greg he
had fallen back into the chair a
blackish gout of blood running from the
hole in his temple he stared sightless
lay into the light with eyes that were
to Gnarls of shrunken brown flesh like
knots in a pine board AUSA Greg was
blind had been since that night three
years passed when the acid splashed
I never knew anyone so keenly alive to a
joke as the king was he seemed to live
only for joking
to tell a good story of the joke kind
and to tell it well was the surest road
to his favor thus it happened that his
seven ministers were all noted for their
accomplishments as Jokers they all took
after the king too and being large
corpora and oily men as well as
inimitable Jokers
whether people grow fat by joking or
whether there is something in fat itself
which predisposes to a joke I have never
been quite able to determine but certain
it is that a lean Joker is a rare Avis
and Terrace about the refinements or as
he called them the ghost of wit the king
troubled himself very little he had an
especial admiration for breath and a
jest and would often put up with lengths
for the sake of it over niceties we read
him he would have preferred Raleigh's
gargantuan to the zadig of Voltaire and
upon the whole practical jokes suited
his taste far better than verbal ones at
the date of my narrative professing
jesters had not altogether gone out of
fashion at court several of the great
continental powers still retain their
fools who wore motley with caps and
bells and who were expected to be always
ready with sharp witticisms at a
moment's notice in consideration of the
crumbs that fell from the Royal table
our king as a matter of course retained
his fool the fact is he required
something in the way of folly if only to
counterbalance the heavy wisdom of the
seven wise men who were as ministers not
to mention himself his fool or
professional jester was not only a fool
however his value was trebled in the
eyes of the king by the fact of his
being also a dwarf and a [ __ ] dwarfs
were as common at court in those days as
fools and many monarchs would have found
it difficult to get through their days
days are rather longer at court than
elsewhere without both a jester to laugh
with and a dwarf to laugh at
but as I've already observed your
jesters in 99 cases out of a hundred are
fat round and unwieldy so that it was no
small source of self gradual ation with
our king that in hopfrog
this was the fools name he possessed a
triplicate treasurer in one person I
believe the name hopfrog was not that
given to the dwarf by his sponsors at
baptism but it was conferred upon him by
general consent of the several ministers
on account of his inability to walk as
other men do in fact hopfrog could only
get along by a sort of interjectional
gait something between a leap and a
wriggle a movement that afforded
illimitable amusement and of course
consolation to the king for
notwithstanding the protuberance of his
stomach and a constitutional swelling at
the head the king by his whole court was
accounted a capital figure but although
hopfrog through the distortion of his
legs could move only with great pain and
difficulty along a road or floor the
prodigious muscular power which nature
seemed to have bestowed upon his arms by
way of compensation for deficiency in
the lower limbs enabled him to perform
many feats of wonderful dexterity where
trees or ropes were in question or
anything else to climb at such exercises
he certainly much more resembled a
squirrel or a small monkey than a frog
I'm not able to say with precision from
what country hopfrog originally came it
was from some barbarous region however
that no person ever heard of a vast
distance from the court of our King
hopfrog
and a young girl very little less
dwarfish than himself although of
exquisite proportions and a marvelous
dancer had been forcibly carried off
from their respective homes in adjoining
provinces and sent his presence to the
king by one of his ever victorious
generals under these circumstances it is
not to be wondered at that a close
intimacy arose between the two little
captives indeed they soon became sworn
friends hopfrog who although he made a
great deal of sport was by no means
popular had it not in his power to
render true petaa many services but she
on account of her Grace and exquisite
beauty although a dwarf was you
personally admired and petted so she
possessed much influence and never
failed to use it whenever she could for
the benefit of hopfrog on some grand
state occasion I forgot what the king
determined to have a masquerade and
whenever a masquerade or anything at
that kind occurred at our court then the
talents both of hopfrog
and troupe Etta were sure to be called
in to play hopfrog and a special was so
inventive in the way of getting up
pageants suggesting novel characters and
arranging costumes for masked balls that
nothing could be done it seems without
his assistance the night appointed for
the fete had arrived a gorgeous Hall had
been fitted up under Tripp Etta's eye
with every kind of device which could
possibly give a claw to a masquerade the
whole court was in a fever of
expectation as for costumes and
characters it might well be supposed
that everybody had come to a decision on
such points many had made up their minds
as to what roles they should assume a
week or even a month in advance and in
fact there was not a particle of
indecision anywhere except in the case
of the king and his seven ministers why
they hesitated I never could tell unless
they did it by way of a joke more
probably they found it difficult on
account of being so fat to make up their
minds at all events time flew and as a
last resort they sent for Tripp Etta and
hopfrog
when the two little friends obeyed the
summons of the king they found him
sitting at his wine with the seven
members of his cabinet council but the
monarch appeared to be in a very ill
humour he knew that hopfrog was not fond
of wine for it excited the poor crippled
almost to madness and madness is no
comfortable feeling but the king loved
his practical jokes and took pleasure in
forcing hopfrog to drink and as the king
called it to be merry come here hopfrog
said he as the jester and his friend
entered the room swallow this bumper to
the health of your absent friends here
hopfrog side and then let us have the
benefit of your invention we want
characters characters man's something
novel out of the way we're wearied with
this everlasting sameness
come drink the wine will brighten your
wits hopfrog endeavored as usual to get
up a jest and reply to these advances
from the king but the effort was too
much it happened to be the poor dwarfs
birthday and the command to drink to his
absent friends force the tears to his
eyes
many large bitter drops fell into the
Goblet as he took it humbly from the
hand of the tyrant ha roared the ladder
as the dwarf reluctantly drained the
beaker see what a glass of good wine can
do why your eyes are shining already
poor fellow his large eyes gleamed
rather than shone for the effective wine
on his excitable brain was not more
powerful than instantaneous he placed
the Goblet nervously on the table and
looked round upon the company with a
half insane stare they all seemed highly
amused at the success of the Kings joke
and now to business said the Prime
Minister a very fat man yes said the
king come lend us your assistance
characters my fine fellow we stand in
need of characters all of us and as this
was seriously meant for a joke his laugh
was chorused by the seven hopfrog also
laughed although feebly and somewhat
vacantly come come said the king
impatiently have you nothing to suggest
I'm endeavoring to think of something
novel replied the dwarf abstractedly for
he was quite bewildered by the wine
endeavoring cried the tyrant fiercely
what do you mean by that I perceive you
were sulky and want more wine
here drink this and he poured out
another Goblet full and offered it to
the [ __ ] who merely gazed at it
gasping for breath drink I say shouted
the monster or by the fiends the dwarf
hesitated the King grew purple with rage
the courtier smirked try petaa pale as a
corpse advance to the monarch seat and
falling on her knees before him implored
him to spare her friend
the tyrant regarded her for some moments
in evident wonder at her audacity he
seemed quite at a loss what to do or say
how most becoming Li to express his
indignation at last without uttering a
syllable he pushed her violently from
him and through the contents of the
brimming goblet in her face the poor
girl got up the best she could and not
even daring to sigh resumed her position
at the foot of the table there was a
dead silence for about half a minute
during which the falling of a leaf or of
a feather might have been heard it was
interrupted by a low but harsh and
protracted grating sound which seemed to
come at once from every corner of the
room what are you making that noise for
demanded the King turning furiously to
the dwarf the latter seemed to have
recovered in great measure from his
intoxication and looking fixedly but
quietly into the tyrants face merely
ejaculated I how could it have been me
the sound appeared to come from without
observed one of the courtiers I fancy it
was the parrot at the window wetting his
bill upon his cage wires true replied
the monarch as if much relieved by the
suggestion but on the honour of a night
I could have sworn that it was the
gridding of this vagabonds teeth here
upon the dwarf laughed the King was too
confirmed a joker to object to anyone's
laughing and displayed a set of large
powerful and very repulsive teeth
moreover he avowed his perfect
willingness to swallow as much wine as
desired the monarch was pacified and
having drained another bumper with no
very perceptible ill effect hopfrog
entered at once and with spirit into the
plans for the masquerade
I can't tell what was the association of
idea observed he very tranquil II as if
he had never tasted wine in his life but
just after your Majesty had struck the
girl and thrown the wine in her face
just after your Majesty had done this
and while the parrot was making that odd
noise outside the window there came into
my mind a capital diversion one of my
own country frolics often enacted among
us at our masquerades but here it will
be new altogether unfortunately however
it requires a company of eight persons
and here we are cried the King laughing
at his acute discovery of the
coincidence eight to a fraction I and my
seven ministers come what is the
diversion we call it replied the [ __ ]
the eight chained orangutangs and it
really is excellent sport if well
enacted we will enact it remarked the
King drying himself up and lowering his
eyelids the beauty of the game continued
hopfrog lies in the frighted occasions
among the women capital roared in chorus
the monarch and his ministry I will
equip you as orangutangs proceeded the
dwarf leave all that to me the
resemblance shall be so striking that
the company of masqueraders will take
you for real beasts and of course they
will be as much terrified as astonished
oh this is exquisite exclaimed the King
hopfrog
I will make a man of you the chains are
for the purpose of increasing the
confusion by their jangling you're
supposed to have escaped on mass from
your keepers your majesty cannot
conceive the effect produced at a
masquerade by eight chained orangutangs
imagined to be real ones by most of the
company and rushing in with savage cries
among the crowd of delicately and
gorgeously habited men and women the
contrast is inimitable it must be said
the king and the council arose hurriedly
as it was growing late to put in
execution the scheme of hopfrog
his mode of equipping the party as
orangutangs was very simple but
effective enough for his purposes the
animals in question had at the back of
my story
very rarely been seen in any part of the
civilized world and as the imitations
made by the dwarf were sufficiently
beast-like
and more than sufficiently hideous their
truthfulness to nature was thus thought
to be secured the king and his ministers
were first encased in tight-fitting
stockinette shirts and drawers
they were then saturated with tar at
this stage of the process someone of the
party suggested feathers but the
suggestion was at once overruled by the
dwarf who soon convinced the eight by
ocular demonstration that the hair of
such a brood as the orangutan was more
efficiently represented by flax a thick
coating of the latter was accordingly
plastered upon the coating of tar a long
chain was now procured first it was
passed about the waist of the king and
tied then about another of the party and
also tied then about all successively in
the same manner when this chaining
arrangement was complete and the party
stood as far apart from each other as
possible
they formed a circle and to make all
things appear natural hopfrog passed the
residue of the chain and two diameters
at right angles across the circle after
the fashion adopted at the present day
by those who capture chimpanzees or
other large apes in Borneo the grande
saloon in which the masquerade was to
take place was a circular room very
lofty and receiving the light of the Sun
only through a single window at the top
at night the season for which the
apartment was especially designed it was
illuminated principally by a large
chandelier depending by a chain from the
center of the skylight and lowered or
elevated by means of a counterbalance as
usual but in order not to look unsightly
this ladder passed outside the cupola
and over the roof the arrangements of
the room had been left at Repetto
superintendence
but in some particulars it seems she had
been guided by the calmer judgement of
her friend the dwarf at this suggestion
it was that on this occasion the
chandelier was removed its wax and
drippings which and weather so warm was
quite impossible to prevent would have
been seriously detrimental to the rich
dresses of the guests who on account of
the crowd
state of the saloon cannot all be
expected to keep out its center that is
to say from under the chandelier
additional sconces were set in various
parts of the hall out of the way and a
Flambeau emitting sweet odor was placed
in the right hand of each of the
caryatids that stood against the wall
some 50 or 60 altogether the aide
orangutangs taking hot frog's advice
waited patiently until midnight when the
room was thoroughly filled with
masqueraders before making their
appearance no sooner had the clock see
striking however than they rushed or
rather rolled in all together for the
impediments of their chains caused most
of the party to fall and all to stumble
as they entered the excitement among the
masqueraders was prodigious and filled
the heart of the king with glee as had
been anticipated there were not a few of
the guests who suppose the ferocious
looking creatures to be beasts of some
kind in reality if not precisely
orangutangs many of the women swooned
with fright and did not the king taken
the precaution to exclude all weapons
from the saloon his party might soon
have expiated their frolic in their
blood as it was a general rush was made
for the doors but the King had ordered
them to be locked immediately upon his
entrance and at the dwarfs suggestion
the keys had been deposited with him
while the tumult was at its height and
each masquerader attentive only to his
own safety for in fact there was much
real danger from the pressure of the
excited crowd the chain by which the
chandelier ordinarily hung and which had
been drawn up on its removal might have
been seen very gradually to descend
until it's hooked extremity came within
three feet of the floor soon after this
the king and his seven friends having
reeled about the hall in all directions
found themselves at length in its centre
and of course in immediate contact with
the chain while they were thus situated
the dwarf who had followed noiselessly
at their heels inciting them to keep up
the commotion took hold of their own
chain at the intersection of the two
portions which crossed the circle
diametrically and at right angles here
with a rapidity of thought he inserted
the hook from which the chandelier had
been want to depend
and in an instant by some unseen agency
the chandelier chain was drawn so far
upward as to take the hook out of reach
and as an inevitable consequence to drag
the orangutangs together in close
connection and face to face the
masqueraders by this time had recovered
in some measure from their alarm and
beginning to regard the whole matter as
a well contrived pleasantry setup a loud
shout of laughter at the predicament of
the Apes leave them to me
now screamed hopfrog his shrill voice
making itself easily heard through all
the din leave them to me I fancy I know
them if I can only get a good look at
them I can soon tell who they are here
scrambling over the heads of the crowd
he managed to get to the wall when
seizing a Flambeau from one of the
caryatids he returned as he went to the
center of the room leaping with the
agility of a monkey upon the king's head
and thence clambered a few feet up the
chain holding down the torch to examine
the group of orangutangs and still
screaming I shall soon find out who they
are and now while the whole assembly the
apes included were convulsed with
laughter the Jester suddenly uttered a
shrill whistle when the chain flew
violently up for about thirty feet
dragging with it the dismayed and
struggling orangutangs and leaving them
suspended in midair
between the skylight and the floor
hopfrog
clinging to the chain as it rose still
maintained his relative position and
respect to the eight maskers and still
as if nothing were the matter continued
to thrust his torch down toward them as
though endeavoring to discover who they
were
so thoroughly astonished was the whole
company at this ascent that a dead
silence of about a minutes duration
ensued it was broken by just such a low
harsh grating sound as had before
attracted the attention of the king and
his councillors when the former threw
the wine in the face of true petaa but
on the present occasion there could be
no question as to whence the sound
issued it came from the fang-like teeth
of the dwarf who ground them and gnashed
them as he foamed at the mouth and
glared with an expression of maniacal
rage into the upturned countenances of
the king and his seven companions AHA
said at length the infuriated jester a
high begin to see who these people are
now here pretending to scrutinize the
King more closely he held the flambeaux
to the flaxen coat which enveloped him
and which instantly burst into a sheet
of vivid flame in less than half a
minute the whole eight orangutangs were
blazing fiercely amid the shrieks of the
multitude who gazed at them from below
horror-stricken
and without the power to render them the
slightest assistance at length the
flames suddenly increasing in virulence
forced the Jester to climb higher up the
chain to be out of their reach and as he
made this movement the crowd again sank
for a brief instant into silence
the dwarf seized his opportunity and
once more spoke I now see distinctly he
said what manner of people these
massacres are they are a great king and
his seven privy councillors a king who
does not scruple to strike a defenseless
girl and his seven counselors who abet
him in the outrage as for myself I am
simply hopfrog
the Jester and this is my last jest
owing to the high combust ability of
both the flax and the tar to which it
adhered the dwarf had scarcely made an
end of his brief speech before the work
of vengeance was complete the eight
corpses swung in their chains a fetid
blackened hideous and indistinguishable
mass the [ __ ] hurled his torch at
them clambered leisurely to the ceiling
and disappeared through the skylight
it is supposed that trip Etta stationed
on the roof of the saloon had been the
accomplice of her friend in his fiery
revenge and that together they effected
their escape to their own country for
neither was seen again